[Musique]
puis les caricatures aujourd'hui on
pourrait le faire mais quel sens ça
aurai je pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya
d'autres types de blasphème qui se sont
mises en place et que la notion de la
semelle là malheureusement dépassé le
cadre des simples caricature c'est
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de choses de son
ressenti comme du blasphème ou de
l'agression
et comme je le disais précédemment il ya
des nouvelles censures qui se sont mises
en place
nouveau interdite pour moi un dessin de
charrier 200 un truc qui cogne quoi qui
à la fois qu'on a envie de regarder
parce que ça nous fait marrer à la fois
qu'on sur lequel on s'offusque un peu
parce qu'on se voie si j'avais eu à ça
je suis vraiment je suis vraiment une
ordure et on a parfois l'impression que
le dessin est de moins en moins
derrière tolérée mais que c'est une
forme d'expression qui même au sein des
médias
et encombrantes voilà c'est un peu trop
atypique c'est un peu trop libre
peut-être une forme d'expression un peu
trop incontrôlable et sans même parler
d'un journal comme charlie hebdo même
dans les grands journaux classiques
c'est vrai que des fois on les dessins
devient extrêmement consensuelle et il
n'y a pas beaucoup de prise de risque
éditorial de la part de ces journaux et
les dessins viennent un peu insipide
faut dire ciel
j'avais envie que le journal continue
pour moi il pouvait pas s'arrêter
pouvait pas s'arrêter comme ça à cause
de
à cause de ce qui s'était passé quoi en
fait on croit qu'un jour elle sait
quelque chose de pérenne et là on se
rend compte que s'il n'y a pas des mecs
pour dessiner dombes et physique